devo rompere il ghiaccio
che cosa può fare una professoressa per
rompere il ghiaccio
se non un interrogazione avete paura no
vabbè per questa volta lascio correre
però vogliono rompere il ghiaccio
facendo un mini sondaggio per conoscervi
e per conoscere me chi ama la matematica
alzi la mano
sono quasi a casa chi che andava bene in
matematica ai tempi un po meno chi pensa
che il talento matematico sia innato va
bene ne terrò presente adesso conosciuto
voi mi presento io penso che la
matematica sia il fondamento di una
società giusta equa e democratica per
cui per questo motivo ha riformulato
questa bellissima frase del premio nobel
di ma l'ala lo riformulata così un
bambino una bambina un insegnante un
libro una penna e la matematica possono
cambiare il mondo
chi è d'accordo con me di aggiungere una
matematica o mamma diminuiscono le bene
e si diminuiscono
mi capita spesso di vedere questa cosa
perché perché ognuno di voi sarà venuto
in mente oddio cosa c'entra la
matematica con la giustizia
a me veniva il mal di pancia quando
avevo il compito di matematica non
dormivo la notte per prepararmi bene io
ho scelto invece di studiare matematica
e di fare l'insegnante di matematica
perché per me era fondamentale dare gli
strumenti critici e culturali agli
studenti alle studentesse
per cambiare questo mondo per scambiarlo
in meglio e la matematica risulta essere
fondamentale quello che voglio fare con
voi oggi è farvi capire portarvi in
questo mio percorso quindi farvi vedere
che il collegamento c'è tra matematica
giustizia ed equità ho bisogno però che
siate con me cercando di andare oltre
l'orizzonte e capire che c'è bisogno di
una visione diversa della matematica e
quindi di un modello diverso della
matematica lo farò o perlomeno cercherò
di farlo seguendo un ragionamento di
tipo matematico cosa fa per prima cosa
alla matematica fa un'analisi della
situazione e l'analisi della situazione
quale andiamo a vedere che cos'è la
matematica non lo voglio fare con le mie
parole
sarebbe troppo semplice potreste dirmi
non è così
lo faccio con alcune frasi scritte da
mia e studentesse i miei studenti quando
hanno finito il liceo e quindi possiamo
vedere che cosa chiara che oggi fa
l'ultimo anno di medicina iscrisse
questo grazie per avermi fatto vedere la
matematica non solo come un insieme di
formule ma come un modo di affrontare la
vita
semplificando la grazie al ragionamento
e alla fantasia la quinta è quella che i
miei studi mi i miei colleghi dicevano
una classe di disperati sbagliando
perché persone che vedrete in grado di
scrivere questo non macchiano di
speranza anzi ne hanno molta è questa
grazie per averci regalato la libertà e
per averci insegnato a ragionare ea
vivere l'ultima e bianca bianca fa
l'ultimo anno di fisica
e mi ha scritto questo grazie per avermi
dato occhi per cercare nuove terre ea
questo punto io quando mi sono trovato a
queste frasi
io con le mie ore di matematica ai miei
integrali le mie cose
ho fatto questo bene allora loro mi
hanno indicato la strada di andare oltre
ancora oltre e pensare di cambiare
questo metodo di insegnamento ma la
matematica perché la matematica è come
hanno detto i miei studenti e le mie
studentesse libertà e forza liberante
cosa hanno scritto loro e questo è uno
strumento potente che ci permette di
essere quello che noi vogliamo essere
oltre stereotipi e pregiudizi
guardate questo loro hanno scritto
vivere la matematica è vita un modo di
semplificare la vita ma perché lo è chi
ce lo dice ce lo dice daniel cane man
daniel cane man è uno psicologo premio
nobel nel 2002 di economia
lui si è occupato di teoria delle
decisioni se voi ci pensate in ogni
momento noi decidiamo una statistica ci
dice che in un giorno
noi decidiamo 35 mila volte e siamo
sicuri che quelle decisioni siano solo
nostre
o non siano condizionate voi oggi avete
deciso di venire qui se non fosse venuti
qui probabilmente non uscire non sareste
quelli che farete quando uscirete da qui
quindi questo è fondamentale ma queste
decisioni come le prendiamo la maggior
parte delle decisioni ci dice daniel
cane ma sono prese in base a quello che
lui definisce sistema 1
ma veloce agisce velocemente ma è
stereotipato e si basa su e soprattutto
sulle mozioni sui ricordi quello che si
dice
la pancia questo ma la decisione così
siamo sicuri che le strategie che noi
prendiamo e le decisioni che prendiamo
con questo sistema 1 stiano le nostre e
non siano frutto di stereotipi
vi faccio vedere uno stereotipo
semplicissimo se voi incontrate un uomo
piccolo uomo perché con una donna
sarebbe ancora elevato al massimo avremo
una questione di genere che non voglio
mettere questo mi chiedete a quest'uomo
che lavoro fai
e lui mi risponde che faccio un
intellettuale
voi che cosa pensate che faccia la
maggior parte delle persone dice
filosofo uno scrittore i miei studenti
dicono niente però scherzi a parte
lasciamo questo lui lui invece risponde
sono un matematico e lavoro alterne di
ginevra bene eppure nessuno mai risponde
questo perché perché c'è lo stereotipo
che i matematici gli scienziati e così
via
siano semplicemente dei tecnici e non
facciano un lavoro di tipo intellettuale
allora daniel cane ma ci dice che se
vogliamo decidere in modo consapevole
si deve attivare quello che lui chiama
sistema 2 che è un sistema come lui dice
educato ed educa bill e razionale logico
ma lento e quindi se noi vogliamo che le
nostre decisioni siano solo nostre
dobbiamo attivare questo secondo sistema
allenarlo e farlo diventare in grado di
controllare se le soluzioni prese dal
sistema 1 siano corrette bene questo
sistema 2
non è altro che la mater per me il
pensiero matematico cioè davanti a un
problema fare un'analisi dei dati
risolve capire quali sono quelli
fondamentali e quali sono quelli
accessori impostare una strategia
verificarla se si sbaglia reimpostata e
arrivare diritti all'obiettivo
questo è il pensiero matematico e questo
ci regala la libertà che hanno detto i
miei studenti quindi deve diventare
veloce bene ma mi dite che c'entra
lorella la giustizia e allora andiamo a
vedere che cos'è la giustizia
consideriamo il piano
il piano è uno dei più grandi giuristi
romani se non il più grande giurista
romano e lui ci dice che la giustizia è
la costante perenne volontà di dare a
ciascuno ciò che gli spetta di diritto
sam filosofo ed economista indiano che
si occupa dei diritti civili che cosa ci
dice il concetto di disuguaglianza non
consiste solo nella disparità di reddito
ma soprattutto nella disuguaglianza di
opportunità di possibilità di scelta di
libertà individuale è fondamentale per
ogni individuo avere la libertà di
decidere con come concepire se stessi
quindi se uno stato deve dare a ciascuno
e ciascuna la libertà di diventare
quello che si vuole essere e le stesse
opportunità
vuol dire che un metodo matematico deve
portare la competenza matematica a tutti
e tutte ecco che allora il mondo un
modello di insegnamento della
tematica si deve fondare prima di tutto
su quello
scusate mi sembra il gergo matematico su
quello che è un assioma fondamentale non
uno non una di meno nella matematica e
nella vita perché se anche lascio fuori
una sola persona
dimentico una persona e quindi lo stato
risulta essere uno stato non giusto e
non è co
ma allora mi direte come fare lorella
qual è la seconda cosa dobbiamo andare
ricordiamoci sempre quello che abbiamo
detto all'inizio oltre l'orizzonte
pensare qualcosa anche che non c'è
dobbiamo cambiare la figura
dell'insegnante dell'insegnare
matematica quindi far che cosa fare
un'altra cosa e secondo assioma la
matematica è per tutti e tutte quindi
non esistono per questo vi ha fatto
alzare le mani
non esistono persone non dotate non
esistono solo persone non allenate o
persone condizionate dagli stereotipi
chi ce lo dice ce lo dice carol 2 carlo
ii è una psicologa cognitiva di stanford
in riferimento mondiale della psicologia
cognitiva e sociale
lei ci dice che sono solo le condizioni
familiari e di scolastic che in qualche
modo condizionano lo sviluppo del
talento
quindi che cosa bisogna fare
l'insegnante ce lo dice sempre lei e dà
un consiglio a genitori e insegnanti che
è questo
mettete da fornite sempre situazioni
sfidanti ai vostri figli figlie studenti
studentesse fate sì che si applichino
e premiate l'impegno e non la
performance perché è solo in situazioni
sfidanti che si sviluppa questo modo di
procedere perché se la matematica e
forma di pensiero è un modo di
affrontare la vita io devo allenare il
pensiero matematico come in palestra
quindi devo far lavorare i miei muscoli
devo sviluppare la capacità di intuire
immaginare progettare ed è dura e
controllare per poi misurare e
quantificare fenomeni infatti della
realtà questo è la cosa importante
quindi situazioni sfidanti perché perché
comunque il l'errore non è un limite ma
è un'opportunità un'opportunità di
riflessione e di crescita
quindi voi avete visto che matematica
giustizia ed equità vanno di pari passo
ma allora resta un'ultima sfida che
vorrei riuscire a combattere con voi che
è questa l'italia e molti paesi sono
agli ultimi posti dell'analfabetismo
funzionale per quanto riguarda la
matematica quindi la matematica
il nostro è uno stato giusto ed equo
deve entrare in tutte le case non solo
nei ragazzi e ragazze ma in tutti noi in
tutti gli adulti è questa è l'ultima
nostra sfida
ed è quello di far arrivare la
matematica ovunque bene forse qualcuno
starà pensando che questa è utopia non
succederà mai
e da matematica quale sono dico che quei
basta solo trovare la strategia giusta
perché come diceva il grande adriano
olivetti tutto il termine utopia è la
mia maniera più comoda per liquidare
quello che non si ha voglia capacità o
coraggio di fare un sogno sembra un
sogno
fino a quando non si comincia da qualche
parte
solo allora diventa un proposito cioè
qualcosa di infinitamente più grande e
oggi il sogno di lorella non può essere
realizzato se non grazie anche a voi
e quindi suoniamo insieme grazie
[Applauso]